well this movies brought new meaning to
the intro of my Fifty Shades freed
review as for sure the happy time
murders so the happy time murders is a
puppet human-hybrid ranch cop comedy
yeah I leave to kiss at home for this
one it's directed by Brian Henson the
son of legend Jim Henson of Jim Henson
productions and I believe is currently
the chairman of Jim Henson productions I
think in any case this is the world
where puppets are real then someone
starts killing puppets so Melissa
McCarthy is a cop that gets brought in
on the case and her ex-partner who's a
PI who's also a puppet they team up to
solve the happy time murders that's
movie out the gate not gonna lie I
cracked up it was just funny it's funny
seeing puppets be so dirt granted that's
the hook it's very simple and it's gonna
wear on you halfway through the movie
but initially it's just such a violation
of your childhood I really dug that not
all the jokes were cheap - I don't know
what was ad-libbing and what wasn't but
there were a few times I was like that
was a clever joke
it was a clever joke in the sense that
it works for the world they live in a
comedy with a unique world should have
their jokes help flush out the world I
felt like this movie did that a couple
times I was like that's a joke
specifically for a world with puppets
they just came so naturally you feel
like these are the insults people sling
around all the time I appreciated that
and of course the puppets means
second-class citizens people don't
respect them they're not able to get
certain jobs are not welcome in certain
places it lends itself to allegory of
racial and social tensions in our world
so pretty much this is the Netflix movie
bright but with puppets I mean in terms
of cop chemistry I've seen worse I've
seen worse cop chemistry than Melissa
McCarthy and a puppet it's weird to say
that is a fact now granted the novelty
of raunchy puppets is gonna wear off
about halfway through the movie so at
that point when the novelty does wear
off you're stuck with the characters
general plot and mystery of who's doing
these murders luckily at that point the
movie hooked me and I was interested in
going along with these characters and
solving the case solving the case that
to its core it's a cliche thing we've
seen it a hundred times before
people are dying who is it gotta solve
it they put a new spin on it and like a
good comedy they recognize they're still
telling a story not all of the jokes
landed couple of the puppet interactions
I was like all right yeah you're taking
the easy route on jokes here come on
that happens in a lot of comedies but in
a world where this movie has kind of a
clever premise suppose it sticks out a
little more when things don't land
I don't know what the rewatch ability
factor is since now I've now experienced
really raunchy puppets like puppets that
harken back to Jim Henson production
puppets so first hour and a half
run time for this movie it's the perfect
run time I don't know people are
expecting for this movie but I wanted a
depraved puppet comedy that people
shouldn't take kids to that I would
laugh at because I'm a fucked-up human
being with a really dark sense of humor
something you don't know that about me
because hey you don't see all of me on
YouTube I don't give a [ __ ] made me
laugh act I thought it was a good time
no alcohol required I could totally see
this as a movie that gets bagged on and
Rotten Tomatoes but hey I'm the weirdo
who liked it whatever assuming I got my
eye perfect alright happy time murders
have you seen what should you think
about it better feedback comment below
let me know God porn was right that does
burn as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see bar that was silly
string by the way
[Music]